Since the XScale, as I mentioned, is a logarithmic scale,
we'll change the linear function here to log and
the domain this time maps from around 250 to 100,000 and their range we want
on map2 corresponds to the width of our SVG element, in this case, 300 pixels.
But let's put a little bit of a buffer on the right end of the SVG element.
In this case, since the x coordinate isn't inverted for
SVG, we simply want to map from zero to, let's say, 250.
And what this says is the value of 250 in
our domain maps to a range value of zero.
And the value of 100,000 in our domain maps to a range value of 250.
And in between 250 and 100,000,
we apply a log arithmetic transform to find out how it should scale saving
this scale in a variable x, we now have a scale for both our y, and our x axis.
In our case, I don't want to deal with the radius of the circle for
simplicity's sake.
But you could also define a third scale that corresponds to the radius of
the circles you draw.
And in the get minder case it will correspond to the population of the country.